(upbeat music)
- I am from a very small town
in Texas called Newcastle.
I love Texas, it's my home,
but it's so limited as to what you can do,
so Clash is really a doorway to the world.
I'm Jett Blackheart, I'm
the leader of Clash Babes.
- [Interviewer] So what
are the Clash Babes?
- Clash Babes are an
organization of female players
of Clash of Clans, and we
come together where we setup
a war with another clan.
A lot of guys think that
they're going to go up
against the Clash Babes and
it's gonna be an easy win.
- Jett Blackheart's
going down, just saying.
- [Jett] But once the war gets started--
- We've got one blue remaining up there.
Not good, come on, come
on, come on, come on.
That's not good.
- They realize we're just
as badass as everyone else.
It's not just about Clash,
but it's the social aspect
and how global it is.
- I'm Emyoe, I live in Khartoum, Sudan.
I feel comfortable with my Clash Babes.
We come together as a team.
- Wizard towers and
X-bows, I do those last.
- We help each other.
Killing me, by the way.
- We're ready for the Babes war.
- They like me who I am.
- I'll talk to you after while.
I am so proud of the Clash Babes.
We have come so far.
It is a constantly ever-changing,
evolving mix of awesome women.
We've got Clash Babes from all
over, pretty much every state
in the United States.
There's Egypt, the Sudan, India,
England, Scotland, Ireland, Sweden,
Serbia, Indonesia, the Philippines.
But there's a lot of
other women out there,
'cause you can never have
too many Clash Babes.